[Musique]
ce château n'est pas
tout ça c'est fait
venu
[Musique]
l'histoire
alors nathalie quel ballon du ve dans un
bleu et rose inverse comment avec lequel
avec petites oreilles l'a1
tiens tiens bon jour mais mais je vous
connais pas vous à vous êtes encore
jamais venue sur l'île aux enfants
c'est bien ce que je me disais ça fait
rien je suis bien content de voir kevin
atelier regarde il ya des nouveaux amis
qui viennent d'arriver
ce qui m'étonne vous savez c'est que
d'habitude quand il ya des nouveaux sur
l'île aux enfants
je suis toujours prévenues et là je vais
pas été enfin ça te rien tant pis en pis
vendent en mieux bienvenue sur l'île aux
enfants
moi je m'appelle françois françois oui
je suis le marchand de ballons du jardin
qui se trouve juste au milieu de l'île
aux enfants
en réalité je suis un étudiant mais
comme il faut gagner sa vie eh bien je
vends des ballots aux enfants ils ont
nathalie tout à l'heure je te devrait-on
ballon vers 1
d'abord on va présenter sabrina à nos
nouveaux amis allez on y va
sabrina wind gardien regarde la surprise
au regard un regard là bas il ya des
nouveaux amis qui viennent d'arriver
approché rené venez venez voir sabrina
bonjour je m'appelle sabrina c'est bête
j'aurais aimé faire une petite fête pour
votre arrivée mais pourquoi ne m'as-tu
rien dit toi qui est toujours au courant
de toutes les
arrivée d'un lycée mais on m'a rien dit
nous on n'a rien dit je parte une lettre
officielle
sabrina à la plus jolie boutique de
l'île aux enfants regarder ça elle vend
de tout vraiment des cordes à sauter des
moulins vente des carnets de la guimauve
des glaces de tout ce formidable non
vallat casimir et demi au lieu de citer
toute ma boutique tu ferais mieux de
venir nos amis pour qu'ils ne se
battront pour finir bien finir dont vous
entendez la voix est un des descendants
d'une très vieille famille de monstres
un de ses ancêtres avaient au cours de
l'ère secondaire ya longtemps réussi à
chasser de lille les féroces
tyrannosaurus qui s'y trouvaient après
un combat singulier terrine avec le chef
de la tribu et depuis bien mon dieu les
ancêtres de casimir vivent des jours
paisibles dans l'île aux enfants sans
s'en faire
j'appelle d'accord casini et participe
aux débats bien avoir en face à brina
bonjour bonjour aujourd'hui chill
thébaux aujourd'hui nos regards hagards
regarde regarde quand il ya des enfants
que je n'ai jamais vu mais n'aie pas
peur n'aie pas peur mais enfin qu'est
signant n'ai pas peur ils sont très
gentils tous et ils sont de la troisième
chaîne dans ses bras la wiwi divison
laisse un pack mieux mais je vois on dit
si je faisais une petite dans sa
résidence à l'école ou basique et semir
allaitement papam papables papam param
param param papa part
padam padam padam padam padam padam
padam bonjour mademoiselle sabrina dont
jean-françois autant aujourd'hui par un
acteur c'est un secteur à
voilà je m'en vais te douter et et
douter que la lettre de ce matin vous
annoncer l'arrivée de nouveaux enfants
dans l'île c'est pareil à chaque fois il
y a le temps pour lui fit ciel changeant
de l'homme aurait deux ans parlons-en
justement j'ai rien su et pas reçu cette
lettre fekter mais je l'avais donné à
casimir ce matin puisque je savais qu'il
venait qui venaient au jardin il vous
l'a pas remis ce que nos aînés
non il n'a pas donné casimir n'a pas
beaucoup de têtes
casimir qu'est ce que tu as fait de la
lettre qu'est ce que c'est un facteur
très bon jeu et vous allez être très
content a avant de venir au jardin je
suis passé à la poste et j'ai mis dans
la boîte
la lettre que vous m'aviez donné qu'elle
va arriver très vite
mais il fallait la remettre à françois
c'est moi même qui l'avait qui l'avait
mise dans la boîte aux lettres et tu lui
a remise